later. All right, so here we are. It's a Zoom call for 9-26-18. And it's being recorded for everybody
to listen to, and I'll get this up on Facebook as soon as possible. So, this little section here,
this little initial talk I had titled, Guard Your Heart. And I think this is so important for us
to better if we have a serious disease or not, because this is how we're supposed to live
at least in my opinion, but especially for those dealing with any serious disease, there's a couple
points. And I could go on when I'm sure you've gone and preached many sermons on this information,
but I just want to share a couple things that have just done my heart today.
So number one, we guard our heart, because we know that sickness and death is harmless to people of
God. So it is the ultimate concern of the enemy, that his purpose is to still kill and destroy,
and not only to kill us physically, but to kill us emotionally, and to take away our hope,
and to take away our focus, and to take away what we're supposed to be thinking about and
concerned with, and he replaces that with fear, and he replaces that with anxiety, and he replaces
that with stress and just sympathetic responses of our body. And it's difficult when we're in a lot
of pain or where we see our future as being less than hopeful to stay focused. And we need to work
at that. And that is really a, that is, that is a work of our flesh. It is a choice and a decision
that we have to make on a daily basis. That is really, I believe, what the Apostle Paul spoke about,
what he said to fight the good fight. He said, I have fought the good fight, and I have run the race,
and that's the race that we run. We're not fighting the fight to stay in good pleasure with God.
We're not fighting the fight to be accepted by God. God accepted us not because of our good works,
but because of what what he has done on the cross 2000 years ago. Through that, we are fully accepted,
we are fully forgiven. It's not by our works that we can boast. But our fight that we do have in this
flesh is to fight against the, the woes of the enemy, what he's trying to trick us. And we need to
remember these things and to encourage what another in these things, especially when we're going
through difficult times. That sickness and death have no, no sting over us anymore. That yeah,
we will be sick as, you know, there's probably nobody that's going to get around that in life.
There's nobody that's going to get around death in life. We're all going to pass away unless
we're here with the Lord returns. But it doesn't have its sting anymore. There's no more victory in
death because that was overcome at the cross in resurrection of Jesus Christ. And if we're holding
fast to that, there is no more fear in that. We're going to give some practical steps of that in
just a minute. The second thing is to hold fast in our mind. This is not our home, but I've spoken
of this multiple times before that if we're focused on this little tedious liver of time that we have
here on earth, whether it's 50, 60, 80, 90, 120 years, however long we're going to live, that is just
literally a pinpoint on a line that that goes on forever and ever and ever. So we have to make sure
we keep in a turtle perspective in everything that we do and the things that we're going through,
the things that we're struggling with, and the things that we take joy in, that yes, we can take
joy in that wonderful relationship we have with our spouse or with our grandkids or the taste of a
hamburger, but it is literally a pinpoint on the realm of eternity. And we need to focus on that.
I'm not going to go through all these scriptures in here. You can look at them and go through them
afterwards so that we don't take too long in this presentation. But it's a practical solution.
Number one, take captive every thought. That is a huge piece of practicality there that I am
reminded of in my life. Don't let your thoughts wander to negative thought processes.
There's multiple affirmations out there that talk about learning how to be grateful and writing
down what you're grateful for at the end of every day, journaling and writing down in your journal,
things that you're struggling with and things that you're grateful with. All those things are
beneficial and whatever works for you, it's important to try to use, utilize those tools. But the key
component to that is don't let your thoughts wander off of the truth. It's easy to do, especially in
social media, climate that we live in today where there's so much negativity and and nastiness and
just easy to complete it in my realm. But I can go off the the bad way, get on the dangers of
vaccinations and the dangers of poorly prescribed medications and people that are pushed into
dangerous medical situations and health situations. But I have to be really careful and take my
thoughts captive there and go, okay, is this what I really need to be focused on? Is this really
serving myself and serving my patients the best of those that can't put in front of me? So
taking captive every thought is really important. Here's some practical solutions for doing so.
Number one is a quote that I said years and years ago, pity is a pleasure I cannot afford.
I've said that multiple times, I think to you people, I've written some blog posts on this as well.
pity is something I call it a pleasure because it can be a pleasure. It's really fun to have your
own pity party. It's really fun to feel sorry for yourself and why, why do I have this disease?
And I saw somebody in the grocery store who was 200 pounds overweight and 75 years old and he
needed a donut and one head and a beer and the other, okay, would have been a grocery store. But it's
easy to say why be Lord. How come I have this? And that is not a path that you want to walk down. That
is not a pleasure that you can afford. That will bring you to a place that you will wish you were
never, never chose to go there. So I said, this over and over again, this self pity is something
you should alone. And it just just keep that in your mind. That's not going to take you where you want
to go. Secondly, to remind yourself, what's spilling out of your pot? This is basically taken from a
get rid of the passage where it talks about that we are all just earthen vessels. Head is what we put
in our earthen vessels. That makes the difference because we could spend our whole life shining up the
outside of our pot if we want to use that as an analogy. And we could paint it really pretty colors
and we could put high gloss on it and it looks really shiny on the outside. But what's on the inside
is that is what matters. And we're really talking about when when you encounter difficult circumstances,
your pot wiggles a little bit and it spills out what's on the inside. That's where I think
difficult circumstances are a blessing in one's life because it reveals to you what's really on the inside
because most of us could live in this wonderful country we call America where really,
you know, you're not starving to death. You have plenty of things. You have multiple TV sets and
DVDs and bad VCRs. You really could do anything you really want to. Yeah, maybe you can't take a
three-month cruise across the Atlantic. But really from a relativity standpoint,
we are living to the top one percent not only of this world as far as this current world that we
live in as far as affluence goes, but really throughout entire history of mankind, the affluence
that we have today and the ease that we have today. You're not just like your ancestors of two,
maybe three generations ago where they had to go cut wood and go shoot a rabbit for dinner tonight
or the family was going to starve and living a dirt floor homes and with the outhouse as a pot in
the back of the wood shed is we live in such unbelievable comfort and it's easy to have just
your pot is just nicely painted with maybe all sorts of religious symbols and godly things and
pictures of Jesus in the cross and it makes people who you know as they see you that we they can see
oh that person is so holy and godly but really when trouble comes at the table wiggles a little bit
that the pot shakes and what is on the inside of the pot starts to come out is a revelation to really
what's inside and that is a wonderful thing if what spills out of my pot is anger and frustration
and bitterness and and all sorts of vile things like jealousies and upsetness and if that's what
spilling out of my pot then I am not walking around in a feeling of the Holy Spirit because if I'm
walking in the feeling of the Holy Spirit what will spill out of my pot at times of adversity is
going to be peace and patience and kindness and self-control and gentleness and those are the things
that I want to spill out of my pot but it's not that I can have that I need I need a feeling of the
Holy Spirit to have that produced in my life to have that fill my pot it's not that I'm going to
okay what are ten steps to peace what are five easy ways to gentleness there's another role with
taking positive steps to try to change your your character but ultimately these fruits of the spirit
are things that grow out of a tree that's rooted in Christ so it is if we're using our analogy of the
pot if we're going to have peace and patience and godliness and and and love and and graciousness and
self-control spill out of our pot that has to come from God so we need to ask for it it's a gift
of the Holy Spirit so that's what when I see my thing is spill out of my pot that I don't like which is
on a daily basis that I need to say I'm sorry repent of that and ask for that fresh filling of the
Holy Spirit and those gifts of the Holy Spirit so that when people do bump into me in the grocery
store in my clinic in the car at home what spills out of it is what I want to be spilling out of it
thirdly a good question that I have learned to ask a long time ago who can I bless today
and whether it's going to the coffee shop or going to the store who can I bless today who can I
just be a little blessing to who can I give a tip to who's never gotten a tip before who can I just
be kind to who can I just ask them how their day is with sincerity and not looking for something in
return it's just practical solutions to take every captive take every thought captive and start
putting my mind at other people other than myself because that's what I flesh wants to do what's
think about me all the time and how do you not think about me all the time you ask God for the ability
to do that in some practical steps that you could go over number four where do my idols lie
this is a tough one for a lot of people because it really confronts real idolatry in our life and
most of us will go well I don't know idolatry I don't worship or I didn't you know build a
totem pole in my backyard that I that I bow down to but really you want to see what your idols are
look at what you spend the most time at so where do you invest your time and money
that is an idol in your life and we have to confront those things we have to tear down those idols we
have to be willing to confront that okay maybe I don't need to watch football so much maybe I don't
need to to even be concerned about things that maybe like even healing my cancer I don't need to
be obsessed with it where are your obsessions if your obsessions are on anything other than your
relationship with God you need to question that obsession you need a question that is that did God
give you that obsession for this right now or is this coming from my flesh and my desires I'm
not here to tell you where they are that's something everybody needs to confront in their own
life all these are and I confront these I have to confront these all the time because I'm a sinful
person so this or things that I'm just try to give you hints practical solution number two
don't why you even exist don't why we even exist so practical solution was a number one was take
every thought captive secondly maybe this should have a number one don't why you even are why are we
even here why do I even exist and this could be really the foundational piece of everything that we
everything that we that we stand for everything that we are every every decision that we make
when we start thinking so so selfishly so narcissistically that that everything is about
us and and you know why do I have this cancer why do I have this disease this life isn't fair
it's really because we forgot why we are and I'm going to give you some ideas and we could go on with
some biblical ideas and why we are I'm just going to give you some things that I just put together for
this we are here to bring God glory that's what I believe maybe you believe differently but I believe
I'm here to glorify my Heavenly Father that's why I'm here that's why I exist that's why I do what I do
in helping cancer patients it's ultimately to bring God glory so and I said this multiple times and
I'm sorry if it upsets you but I'm not here to to help a person live an extra 10 years with their
cancer that they're supposed to die 10 years ago and having to still die it go to hell that is not my
purpose and I know why is it enough to know that it's only God who could change a person's heart
and to grant salvation to someone but ultimately it's my purpose to bring God glory and to be
a picture of him in people's life and I'm the first one and I'll apologize right now what I'm not
that way which is daily and I need to repent of that so in order to do that I need to number one I need
to surrender to his will not my will it's not about me it's not about what I want it's about what is
he wanted my life and I've said this even about my cancer okay I don't want to have cancer and I will
freely tell that to the Lord I don't want to have this Lord I want to be healed but ultimately
is I was bought with a price this isn't about me anymore I know why I'm here I'm not here so that I
can live 90 years and retire at 62.5 and go buy a place in Florida and play golf the rest of my
life and no offense if that's what you're personally doing that's the choices that you made but I know
that's not why I'm here so that is even enter to my realm of reality I need to surrender to his will
Lord what do you want for me if I have been if I've given myself to you and I've surrendered myself
completely to you then it's like Lord they just use me if you choose to use me by allowing me to have
a specific disease for whatever purpose it's to bring you glory then let me bring you glory through
this thing if just like the apostle Paul he used me Lord if it's to to appeal to Caesar so you could
be dragged off to to Rome and be shipwrecked on the way there and almost die and then be bit by a
snake that doesn't let go of your skin and you shake it off in the fire and you still don't die
and now you're able to witness to all these people on this island and have them all come to the
knowledge of Christ and then you get back on the ship and change go to Rome stay in a prison for
two years and obviously be able to testify to multiple people in Caesar's household that because it
says that many of them became believers then praise God and ended up having his head cut off but he
was willing to have his head cut off be you know lashed with with whip 30 times five times shipwrecked
three times it could go on and on with the passages explains his woes he that wasn't what it was about
he was surrendered to the will of God because he knew his purpose his purpose was to bring glory to
his heavenly father and all these other things all these other things just fade away it's easy to
not find you know take pity in on yourself and see what's spilling out of your vessel and such
if you've completely surrendered who is will when I completely surrendered to his will I could do nothing
but repent and I know that he gives me the ability to repent and he shows me what I need to change
repent literally means to turn around the things that I need to turn away from the things I need to
walk away from and the things I need to walk towards he'll give you that he'll give you the desires of
your heart if you pray for it and we have to ask for it says that he will give us the desires of our
heart I don't believe that means he's going to give me a bout and a new Mercedes I think that he that
it means that he's going to put in my heart his desires and I won't desire a boat in a Mercedes
anymore hey I look at a boat hey that's a pretty nice boat I look at a Mercedes hey that's a nice
Mercedes you know about a car guy I could look at something like a Mercedes they wow that's a
pretty pretty car but you know that's not for me because he puts his desires in my heart what I've
surrendered to as well and I don't desire those same things anymore and even though I do still
desire to not have cancer and to to to get better and to be healthy and not to be hungry and not to
not have clothes to wear and not to be in jail ultimately I want a surrender to his will and I want
his name to be glorified in my life and then lastly that's really what walking and sanctification
that words sanctification is a big Bible word that means to walk in holiness that he leads me in I can't
sanctify myself but God helps me walk and sanctification on a daily basis doing just what we do this
that's what this is is is is is walking and sanctification surrendering to him on a daily basis
repenting of the things that you the wrong things that you thought the wrong things that you did it
allowing him to change your direction and move you towards a deeper relationship with you with him
because ultimately our purpose is to be molded and shaped to the image of his son and we do that by asking
for his desires in our heart literally Lord put your desires in my heart that I might bring you glory
and therefore I'm walking and sanctification so just a little practical solutions hopefully
these are things that I go through on a daily basis you know it's it's not a a a contest and holiness
it's not a anything but a personal relationship with your Heavenly Father and when we have that
personal relationship what he fills us with the with his with his holy spirit he fills us our pot up
with that fruit that can only come from a relationship with him that is matured on a daily basis
and then what we are bumped into what life bumps into us what spills out of us is something that
brings him glory that's how we bring him glory so isn't it amazing that we bring him glory just by
surrendering to him and letting him fill us so that our life glorifies him isn't something that we do
that we're so wonderful and aren't we great so that we could take credit for it it has nothing to do
with him when I see God in a person and I see the peace of God the patience of God the holiness of God
in a person I know that it didn't come from that person God put it there and that's what brings him
glory so when you see my flesh raising up and me not acting very godly that's just me and and and I hope
you forgive me for that so all right so now you're going to open it up for questions chat questions did
good come in sometimes it's difficult to see how God is glorified in my sickness boy amen to that
it is difficult to see how God is glorified in my sickness and and that's where that's where we
go back to just surrender Lord how I know many things I believe God can't trust me with I'll just
speak about myself God can't trust me with the answers and if you're if your heartfelt is is Lord how
are you bringing glory in my cell you bringing glory to yourself in my sickness you might might not
be tell you get to heaven that somebody is going to come to you go who is watching you you didn't know
who I was but I watched you through your cancer or your sickness and because of what I saw at you I
gave my life to Jesus Christ and God loves people so much that he will use his children
for that purpose I remember I don't know if I told you the story once we went down to Mexico we were
missionaries in Mexico and we had given up everything here's me widened about this given up everything
to go to Mexico we sold everything we had it went self-supported this full-time missionaries down there
brought our four kids down there were driving back and my wife and two of the kids had flown back
early a couple weeks before and then I drove back with my two oldest and our 10-year-old suburban or
12-year-old suburban with a small little U-Haul trailer that was everything we owed which is still
I understand 10 times more than 90% of the population in this world driving home and our truck started
to break down and I just remember crying out to the Lord my kids um have my kids uh more sleeping
to the back seat I was crying out to the Lord saying uh Lord why did you do this I felt like I literally
felt like being in Mexico ministry to the people that I was putting drops in a bucket that had no bottom
that was my best description for what we I felt like we accomplished um we worked so hard down there
and I just felt like I didn't see any fruit to our labor it was just heartbreaking and the you know
it's very few times that I ever felt like the Lord spoke to me but this was one of them and he said
if if I had you do all of that for just one person would you do it and that was just very
convicted for me uh it was a realization that God if God wants to use me um however he wants to
use me to see one person come to him again it I'm not my own anymore I have been purchased with the
blood of Christ it's not my choice how am I asked or what it wants to use me anymore um and if he
wants to use me for that reason then so be it it's his choice and I'm not here to question him
all right I'm gonna open this up uh to unmute everybody if you have other questions feel free to
I put you. Dr. Connises is Sharon um I remember a week or so ago you talked about entitlement
I I heard that and so I don't want this to be taken the wrong way but I um I was I had a bad couple
weeks and then I had a good day yesterday and then late at night I developed a urinary tract infection
just like out of nowhere so I went to the rif machine and I ran it twice in a row and it seemed like
it relieved a little bit of pain but then I slept through the night and then I ran it again in the
morning and I started just getting like really horrible pain so then I finally had to go to the doctor
and do the antibiotics and I just kind of feel like you know when will the rif machine ever work for me
like I don't you know I know I can't work all the time but how about some times like
am I not using it right or what is going wrong so I think that's a valid question um so you have
to take it in a perspective it's um it did the rif work to dock out your bacterial infection uh no
it didn't um you used the the bacterial program or what did you use it's called the UTI
the UTI program so if you're using the rif remember it's a tool so it's frequency specific so the UTI
infection is a bacterial program and um so but it's set on certain bacteria because you just get put
on the bacterial programs in uh in a short if you think it's an hour program or something isn't it?
yeah um so always look at other programs so let's say I run the UTI program a couple times and
boy this isn't really helping you should switch to go to a bacterial program go to a strep program
go to a staff program do a viral come do the viral come flex program switch programs because it's
frequencies that's number one number two is hitting a bacteria with its old frequencies
if it's a very viral bacteria where it mediates currently in a state of very rapid replication
it might not be enough to knock it down that's where you have to use other tools so that's where
I don't think it was unwise if you at all to go and get a antibiotic and I don't think that you should
think that you it something wasn't working that you had to use a bigger bullet on that to that
situation so I would continue even getting the antibiotic I would continue to run the bacterial and
UTI and the viral programs on it because it will do nothing but help help knock it down it's just like
it's just like okay well somebody took ureco which is something we as a supplement we usually give
for people with UTIs and and Sally took ureco for her UTI and knocked it down and I took it it didn't
work oh my gosh how come this doesn't work well it didn't work for you because yours was a little
bit different it was in a rapid replication you got to use a bit a different tool so just go to a
different tool like you did that was good idea maybe it's time to get an antibiotic I've heard the
same stories of I went got an antibiotic for a bi UTI and it didn't work what should I do well
doesn't need antibiotics are bad for UTIs it just didn't work for yours that time it yours is a
different strain that needs something else so let's try a donation let's try some ureco let's
try antiviral so you just got to try different tools do you have a suggestion for a preventive
because this is something that I kind of have a history of and with being on chemo I'm at higher
risk of infections and stuff so with UTIs I think some other things that you need to consider is
the reason why do women get UTIs and men don't seem to get UTIs
I think there's a reason and the reason is is that women have a uterus and your uterus sits in
front of bladder and and as we hear I'm gonna just mute everybody again so as we as we age our
uterus can tip in our bladder tips with it so then urine can pool and not get fully drained when
we go to urinate so some of the hints that I tell people that I'm really prone to UTIs I have a
history of UTIs well is it it's not really oh we need to use you know just use stronger medication
all the time or oh you need to use the rightful the time you have to go back and ask that one little
three word question three letter question why am I getting a UTIs all the time and many times it's
because my bladder's tipped so our bladder typically tips forward and that's what causes the poolina
that it like an anterior little cup of the bladder so we have to tip the bladder back now it's really
impossible for me to explain that without showing that to you or having a practitioner that's near
you that knows how to tip the bladder and tip the uterus because they both go together that can really
help with that but it's not just with with with with our older there's younger women that anatomically
have a tipped bladder part there's a lot of reasons to it many times when you know
your ladies are athletic that that tendon gets very tight and the bladder of the uterus just tips
forward so those are just other reasons why a person's prone to bladder infections and I think
you need to address those things as well because it's just not it's not a normal thing for a person
to say well I'm just prone to bladder infections and I get a lot of bladder infections there's a
reason why so many times it's structural things other structural things are you go to a chiropractor
is there a neurological impeachment on the nerve that's affecting the bladder that could be a cause
to it another chemical cause of constant bladder infections can be due to food sensitivities
now most of our patients are on more restricted diets so that's not quite an issue but gluten
sensitivity and dairy sensitivity are common with recurrent bladder infections too we had another
question come in on the chat that says I have a lot of total body pain and some more swelling in my
right lymph node is this a result of detoxing going on or is it from the right foreshade I have trouble
fighting a comfortable sleeping position is it okay to position the ball the right ball under my pillow
so several questions so you remember what your lymphatic system does your lymphatic system is
radiating your tissues so your when your tissues are radiated they go through that fluid goes through
the lymph vessels and into the lymph nodes and the lymph nodes are there what the lymph nodes are
think of them as like a local police station with police in there and the police are white blood cells
macrophages t cells to kill anything that's in the lymph system so if the lymph system is draining
the tissues may be draining the spaces between the cells there could be bacteria there there could be
viral infections there and this lymph system is going to drain all the way black to the bloodstream
so we're we got to prevent sepsis so we got it this is these are the main drags that we have to have a
police station to keep bad guys out of bloodstream so the lymph nodes will increase in size if a person
has an infection so if a person has a lot of swelling let's say they have swelling in the legs
therefore they have lymph stasis that's not what we're talking about here so we're talking about
when the lymph nodes themselves get larger it can be due to infection it can be due to cancer so
yes it can be due to the the body's detoxing absolutely so the person has that question it can
be due to the body's detoxing yes it can be due to an infection too so you want to investigate that too
do I have a fever do I have symptoms of like a bug or something like that if you do you want to
address that as well then the second half of that question is I have trouble fighting a comfortable
sleeping position as an okay to position the right bulb under your pillow um yes you can
it partly depends on where your cancer is technically you want the right is close to your
cancer as possible if you're lying on your side put the put the bulb behind you or in front of you
I still think it's probably better to get in your whole body more if it's more by your side it doesn't
have to be touching you remember if it's within six to 12 inches that's great if it if you are
stuggling with it it is touching you that's better but don't worry if it falls if you move around and
you have to set it by your side or whatever don't worry about that if you put it under your pillow it's
Bailey um I mean it's I I guess you can I wouldn't think that would be highly uncomfortable but
um if you're putting if you're thinking to put it on that you're putting it under your pillow and
it's above your head so it's not affected your flexion of your neck um on your lower dorses of your
cervical spine then I would say that it's getting farther away from you so um but whatever works if
that works better that's I think that's fine too you are unmuted again if you try to ask me a question
if it had to go you were muted anything else that's the kind of I have a question uh-huh
um this is Donna from Arkansas um I've been having um pain in my knees for probably about five
months now it came all at once and it affected my both knees at the same time so I'm thinking
that came from the spinal cord um I'm thinking about going to a chiropractor but I also have multiple
myeloma which affects the bones so my question to you is if you're a chiropractor what things should
I look for and I go to find a chiropractor because I can't have somebody manipulating me because I have
osteoporosis yeah so with multiple myeloma I would be there if you go if so first of all let me ask
answer the general question okay um if you go to I get to mute everybody you get okay
if you have um cancer in general not multiple myeloma but you have cancer in general and you don't
believe you have metastasis in the spine let's say you have breast cancer and you last you do you do not
have any metastasis I would say yes go to a chiropractor but you should go to a chiropractor
who takes x-rays um I'm not big in irradiation as you know that however it's better to see and to know
that do not see it to guess so we'll use talk about somebody doing adjustments on your spine
um uh you need you really should see what's going on there um even using you know somebody
people say well my chiropractor uses an activator so it's very gentle and he doesn't take x-rays
well you're probably safe and you're probably not gonna have any problems if the if the chiropractor
is using a very gentle adjusty technique with an activator an activator is a little tool that
makes adjustments that really you can't hurt anybody with it however um still it would be beneficial
for you to get it can be beneficial for you to have a set of x-rays number two if you have a cancer
that you know that there's spinal involvement like you know with with multiple myeloma there's
almost always bony involvement even if you don't know that there's bony involvement with the
spine yet or if you have a cancer that you know that there has been metastasis to other bony areas even
if it's not the spine you have to take even a greater precaution do not go to a chiropractor who's
going to adjust you manually period you need to find somebody who's going to use an instrument like
the activator even if they take x-rays so if you know that you have any bony involvement of cancer you
should only be using an activator for adjustment purposes that's just my opinion so there's just too
much danger in a possible fracture due to just weakening of the bones so that's my general opinion
about chiropractic should get x-rays and should do low-force techniques then to answer your specific
question with I have paid in both of my knees came out at the same time I'm thinking it's probably
coming from the spine therefore um should I go to a chiropractor uh maybe uh possibly then you
really really have to be careful because if uh if you have paid in both these they both came out
at the same time and it is coming from the spine it's coming mainly from the cord and not from uh a
vertebrae that's on a place so a vertebrae that's on a place is typically going to give paid on one
side of the body is that always everybody can be different but it's typically going to give
paid unilaterally not bilaterally so if you have bilaterally paid like that that came out like that
I would think uh that adjustment is probably not in order I would think more of the light of
if you go to a chiropractor that uses physiotherapy like electrostib may help and that would be
electrostib on the spine and yes you could use electrostib on the spine if you have bony cancer there
by opinion um pemf would be perfect for that um uh that that would be like the perfect thing for
that also laser so class four laser emf um electromagnetic frequency um uh typically called ems
sorry electromagnetic stimulation or um uh and or the pemf would be by tools and choice
thank you very much appreciate you i have um this is sharing i have a suggestion to um i was going to
chiropractors for years and my daughter's friend ended up working at a chiropractor that does the
nuka method and you cca and um that has helped me tremendously it's all they do is
adjust your top your your atlas um vertebrae and the first one on the top
and they just put pressure on your neck around near your ear and that's all they do and
it helps line everything else up and it doesn't seem like it should work and it just seems
unbelievable but yeah that's another that's a good suggestion chiro thank you that's another that's
another chiropractic technique that could really be helpful for people there's not a lot of nuka
doctors out there though oh i know dr conner's this is damn i have i have bus cancer that went to the
bones but how do you determine your own versus connected tissue that inflammation goes away and
then i get pain there and that inflammation goes away yeah that's a that's a good question so how do you
determine whether your symptoms are due to what your symptoms are due to period right um sometimes we
kid so um some rules of thumb are if they're following if the if the pain is following a dermatomal
pattern which is um so on your skin you have the intervention of uh
intervention of specific nerves that are coming out of your spine so if you google dermatomal
nerve pattern of pain you'll see a picture of a person standing in a chemical position
and have these different lines on their body of here's pain from c1 c2 c3 c4 t5s you know
all the way down and if it's following that pattern that you could then you could pretty much say oh
it's probably coming from that spinal nerve if it's more general achiness and it's and it's not as
specific of an area and it's covering a little bit broader area um that it's uh it's probably a
pain that's not coming from the spinal cord area it's coming from a local area that's
reflected paid back up to the brain um how do you know if it's coming from the bivody involvement of
the uh of the um the tumor or is it coming from local um inflammation around the um like a ligament
or or something it's it's difficult to tell even if so used to be that oh well if you put ice on it
and it really helps and it was probably local inflammation but when you start to understand
neurology that doesn't always fit that pattern too because you're affecting the receptors that
that are basically that um call me uh you're basically affecting the brain while you do that so
whatever works it doesn't make any difference you don't really need to know what the cause is
the where you really want to know what the cause is what the pain is if you don't already have a
diagnosis of spinal involvement so if somebody calls me it says I have you know x, y, and z paid where
do you think that's coming from but it sounds like it's coming from possible spinal involvement
that it's time to get an x-ray or CT scan to see if there's any any body involved it
I don't seem to have any um restriction on movement or anything so I don't think it's final but
I do you know it's just standing in that area just moving around yeah it's difficult
I mean there's always with pay there's always inflammation so anything that you could do to reduce
the inflammation is usually going to help um and that's why you do things like curcumin
bosphole and ice and and tens units and things like that that are going to decrease inflammation
okay thank you and down that that's another thing that you could use on your knees is that
that would be a really really cost effective approach would be to use a tens unit um
because uh I mean we have if you we you could get a tens unit on Amazon for $35
that it's a nice little tool to use um and it would be safe to use over a body area there so
yes I do use the inflammation on the right hand side it's uh it's almost
it works I can only I mean after I use it then we're going to a couple of hours the pain is
the worst the worst pain in your knees yes okay yeah I mean I I we used to walk you know
several miles a day and I can't walk anymore well it might be good that then what you want to do
typically with the tens unit you put the you put the pack you're the key maybe you need everybody
again yeah what might be good is to experiment by putting the pads in at your spider your knees are
intervened by your L3 nerve mainly your L3 and L4 nerve so you'd have to kind of locate where that is
on your spider by looking at it it had to be a chart all right we we have a tens unit so I probably
should start using it thank you oh yeah that might be good to block that what are you calling
that a tens unit tens unit at T.E.N.S a trans electrical uh neurological uh stimulator transcutaneous
electrical neuro stimulator so that's for people with like maybe like ligament pain and uh that's
for people with ligament pain joint pain muscle pain um really for any pain you wouldn't put it
over an open wound you wouldn't put it over you know you could even put it over a spray dangle um it
was really created for people with chronic pain like disc pain that ever goes away um it's made to be
used 24-7 it's a little teeny like a three inch by four inch by maybe recorder inch deep
thing that could fit in your pocket or clip on your belt and it has the wires that go to like a
two inch by two inch pad or what inch by one inch pad that you'd put over your spot of paid and you
can wear it and live your day and walk around and do your stuff it's like a portable electrical
for your muscles and it you can set it at different frequencies typically it's at 80 to 100
hurts and it helps stimulate it kephlands and adorphins to help knock pain down and it really could
take the ash off they're very inexpensive uh a decent one is 35 bucks really all right if that's it
we've already gone 55 minutes so we better call it quits for the night um thank you
indeed um i appreciate all of you and love you and pray for you so um and maybe next week we'll
get an update sorry i didn't ignore that update i just remembered it all right thank you so much
love you guys thank you thank you thank you bye bye appreciate it